are the top three
um
the top three factors that you would
look for in a woman I'm gonna start with
China
um
femininity
loyalty and peace
obviously not high body counts can't be
run through but that's a standard
there's only three no but no but that's
always in there so that's why it doesn't
like yeah I would yeah so okay so so say
that again which is the top three yeah
so
um uh uh femininity
um
yeah we'll just use that one it can't be
wrong can't be a 304 can't be a three or
four can't have a highlights
four one nine what oh what what
kind of thing no it's not the same thing
one person makes money the other person
gets run through and about yeah you know
it's the same thing how can someone out
there making money be the same as you
have to open up your legs to random men
what if you're getting paid for it
though that makes your [ __ ] oh Lord oh
escort Vibes oh no I'm just saying like
what's the difference what do you mean
sorry what's the difference that there's
a big difference okay
between escort vibes
let her explain no I'm just saying like
if you're calling like a girl with a
high body kind of [ __ ] yeah what's the
difference between if she's getting paid
for it then because Okay cool so
one person knows what they are and they
and they're getting paid for it and the
other person is lying to who they are
okay yeah doing it for free doing it for
free so in actual fact and it's so the
thing I the thing I say right
but a lot of girls say body count
doesn't matter until you ask them what
their body count is and then you hear is
crickets so I'm saying to you oh the
other one is
how many bodies before you think your
whole
but why does that matter to you because
men don't want a woman that's been run
through and because men the thing about
okay so in order for me to sleep with
women yeah I have to have something
about me we'll just listen to this whole
podcast about people having to have some
type of thing about them this includes
money this includes being six foot two
this includes all these other things
right status in order for you in order
for you to sleep with men all you have
to do is go on your Instagram and say
I'm lonely and automatically you're
gonna get men not going to want to
approach you everything
okay okay wait hold on so every girl oh
okay okay not every girl but every
single girl in this room if they went on
their social media and they said I'm
feeling lonely tonight who will come
around and look after me or an actual
fact I'm feeling scared who you know
your DMs will be popular how do you do
that
I'm not saying you would do but some
girls do it for attention no I'm not
saying you would do it but I'm giving
you a metric to go by right so I'm
saying that's how easy it is for you to
get men that want to come around if I do
that people are going to ask my father
for my Instagram to get shut down and
that's the difference right in order for
me to sleep with 10 high quality women I
need to have something about me I need
to have money I need to have status I
need to have something in order for you
to sleep with 10 men all you have to do
is say sleep with me and that's the
difference so you have to so man control
access to relationships women control
access to their body right as sex right
so in order for you to um in order for
you to to to get men all you have to do
is just open your legs and we have to
have some value to us and that's why
it's more important for you to protect
what you have because a woman that opens
their legs to many people is just you
have no
decrease in value of course you do
what what what item gains value the more
you use it
never say okay so if it's your birthday
I don't want a guy that sleeps with
his team organic same way a guy doesn't
want girl a girl that entertains I hear
you but the thing is that most women
like men that other women like so that
goes with the territory it really goes
with the territory
and another thing and another thing is
yeah think about this year uh a lot of
times when guys enter relationships when
guys are single a lot of times they find
it hard to get girls stuff like that and
when they get a relationship oh now all
these girls your girls will know the
guys in a relationship and they want
them more exactly they want them more
yeah your goals because they can't have
married men not married it's easy for
married men to cheat it's very easy yeah
but I have some self-control
no but the point is you're trying to say
that women don't like guys if they've
slept around or whatever that's not true
women don't really care bro no they care
some some women care you're not gonna
want a guy that entertains every girl
that's in Every Girl's Life okay not
sleeping with every guy okay okay I mean
every girl is the same way a guy
wouldn't want that it's not the same
okay maybe some women are different but
some women don't want that okay well I
don't want if that's the case if that's
the case here all of these guys all of
the guys that you've aired all the guys
that you don't consider here why haven't
you taken one of these guys
because I don't want them but I'm
allowed to have an option
of course yeah I'm allowed to have it if
I don't want you I don't want you of
course I don't want to wait on this time
no we we yeah we understand yeah yeah
these questions
I don't want to waste the guy's Time
same way like you wouldn't want your
what your time um wasted yeah I
understand what I'm saying you are
picking the men that can get loads of
other men the men which will actually
treat you good you air them every single
day you do not see them so every time
women are talking about all he's
speaking for me no no no no I'm speaking
for all the women that air the good men
wait hold on a second you don't give
them a chance let me speak yeah yeah no
wait one wait wait stop talking one
voice listen you're doing the same thing
you don't give good men the chance you
don't even give a good man a chance to
speak and put you on some game because
this is what you women do listen to me
for a second right cool all the only
minutes that you see are the charging
the tyrones these top 20 of men that get
older goes here so when you women talk
about oh we don't care about we care
about men that slept around if you
really cared about some men that slept
around you wouldn't get the guy that can
get five chicks at one time and you make
sure an option if he went to all these
guys that you walk past every single day
all the guys that uh I don't want him
why would I want him these guys might
have potential but you've never given
them a chance because all you care about
is Chad and Tyrone then when you link
Chad and Tyrone they move like how Chad
and Tyrone move and they keep us an
option and then all these men do is run
up your body count and make you girls
more more unagreeable do you know why
you become more in agreeable why because
you don't get what you want these man
beats you and leaving one of your
mileage and that's all that happens then
all they do is by the time you meet a
guy that actually cares about you you've
dealt with a lot of these guys and now
you're speaking this guy right like
you're like I don't trust guys I got
choices and that's called emotional
damage so now I've met you now yeah and
I'm the good guy and I've seen you for
all the potential that you are but
already you're not trusting me you're
going through my phone you're trying to
yeah because you're traumatized no no
but yeah but but that's because you
dealt with Chad and Tyrone why that has
nothing to do with me Okay the reason
why I wouldn't want a guy who's got like
a massive high body count if we do go
into a marriage is because let's say we
get married now people aren't going to
be happy for us so you start seeing
about what people think you know you
start seeing side chicks coming out from
Left Right and set up people that he
slept with before saying that this to
stop trying to ruin the relationship
because it's all about you so exactly
what about me what about the men that
you slept with before no I'm just saying
that's a possibility because you know
girls like you said before girls get
jealous when like you know they want the
same guy that you had before in the past
so it's much easier for a girl to like
come out of nowhere or people that he
slept with before who are still
emotionally attached to the man to come
out and be like I think that's equal I
think guys from the past can come out as
well don't you think it's worse
I don't see I don't see why oh it's only
a special woman will come out
what do you mean no but I'm just saying
like for women it's different because
they get mostly attached to a man yes
they do so with a guy every time
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible